- I hope the coffee
flavor is strong enough.
I don't think it's gonna
work when you fry it.
Moment of truth.
(upbeat music)
Hey guys, my name's Gideon.
And you might know me from
TikTok making Filipino food,
fried chicken or really anything crispy.
And today I have a very
special guest with me,
TikTok's heartthrob, Owen Han.
- Hello.
I'm Owen Han.
I'm a food content creator and
I specialize in sandwiches.
So Gideon is the Crispy King,
and I'm gonna put him to the test.
I'm gonna challenge you
to take a non-crispy dish
and make it crispy.
- All right, Owen. What'd you bring me?
- So here we have a classic tiramisu.
This is my favorite dish.
I'm not a sweets guy, but
if I see this on the menu
I'm getting it every time.
Tiramisu literally
translates to pick me up.
So it's like a dish that's supposed to,
you know, make you feel good.
It's light, it's got coffee, mascarpone,
but the thing it's lacking is texture,
and that's where you come in.
You think you can do it?
- I think I got a few tricks,
but we'll see what I can do.
Let's break down the tiramisu.
Well, tiramisu is a really
popular, sweet, creamy,
and coffee flavor dessert,
which typically starts
with a layer of coffee
or espresso soaked lady fingers.
And then on top of that
a layer of lightly sweetened
whipped cream and mascarpone,
and then dusted with cocoa powder.
Traditionally, we soak
lady fingers in coffee,
but obviously that's
gonna be soggy, right?
So I saw this thing on TikTok
where you can make a rice chip,
but instead of using water,
we're gonna use coffee
to have that flavor and keep that crisp.
All right, so first things first,
we're gonna rinse the rice to
get rid of that extra starch.
Now our rice is washed.
Now we're gonna add the coffee
and we're gonna bring this to a boil,
and once it boils, we're gonna
simmer it for about an hour.
You just really wanna overcook the rice,
so it's easier to blend later
'cause we're gonna make paste.
Okay, it's been an hour.
And as you can see the coffee
has been absorbed by the rice,
and it's very overcooked, it's very soft.
Usually you really don't
wanna serve rice like this,
but for this recipe,
this is what you need.
We're gonna blend the overcooked rice
even though it looks really weird,
but you gotta trust the process.
You're just looking for a
really smooth consistency.
(blender whirring)
Okay, this looks great.
It looks like a very loose peanut butter
but that's what you're looking for
'cause we're gonna spread it nice and thin
on a baking sheet.
Now I'm going to spread
the paste that we made,
the coffee rice paste, so we
can put it in the dehydrator.
I hope the coffee flavor is strong enough
so we can taste it in the dish.
But I also hope it's not too strong
that it overpowers the entire thing.
You want it thin 'cause if it's too thick
it takes too long to dehydrate.
So just try your best to keep it even.
Okay, so now I'm gonna scoop the rest
and we'll be right back.
And now we're gonna dehydrate it
with our handy dandy dehydrator.
A dehydrator is pretty much
just like a gentle oven.
It goes slower than a usual oven
and it's more precise and accurate.
If you don't have this,
you can also use an oven.
Okay, so we are going to
dehydrate this for about two hours
or until it looks like a fruit roll up.
Now we're making the tiramisu cream.
I'm gonna keep it traditional.
We have egg yolks and a double boiler.
You're gonna add your sugar.
You want to gently cook the eggs
without turning into scrambled eggs.
And you also don't wanna
serve raw eggs, you know?
Now that it's pale and triple in volume,
I can tell that it's ready to go.
And now we're going to
add our mascarpone cream.
(staff laughing)
(beeps)
(upbeat music)
So we're just folding the mascarpone
in the egg yolk mixture.
(upbeat music)
Our mascarpone in egg yolk mixture
is nice, smooth, and silky.
It's time to make the whipped cream.
I asked for an electric mixer
'cause I got really
tired from the last one.
So you wanna mix just the cream
until it's nice and frothy.
And then we add the sugar.
You wanna whip into like a soft peak
'cause we're gonna fold it
in the mascarpone egg yolk mixture.
So we're gonna add a third of
the whipped cream at a time,
so we can slowly get that
texture that we want.
We want it nice and airy,
and just incorporate
as much air as you can.
All right, I'm happy with this.
We're gonna let this chill,
and let's move on to my
favorite part, which is frying.
Okay, so this is the coffee rice leather
that we've been working on.
This came out perfect.
So it's still flexible.
It's like a fruit roll up,
and it should puff up when we fry it.
So we're gonna cut this in smaller pieces,
so when we fry it we
can stack it at the end.
Doesn't have to be perfect
'cause when we fry it
it's just gonna curl up.
Moment of truth.
If I did this correctly,
it should puff up the
moment it touches the oil.
All right, here we go.
(oil sizzling)
I'm hearing the right sounds.
Now we have our coffee rice chip.
Ta-da.
I'm pretty happy with that.
Okay, so this is exactly
what I was looking for.
Nice and crispy.
Thank god it worked.
Now it's time for assembly
which is my favorite part
'cause it's the easiest,
and we get to eat after.
We have the mascarpone component,
and we have the lady finger component
which is now a coffee rice chip.
I'm just gonna put like
a little dollop of cream
to act as a paste, so that
the the chip doesn't slide.
And we're gonna layer it with a cream.
All right, we're gonna dust
it with a cocoa powder,
and just for that little dramatic
effect, shaved chocolate.
There we have it.
I'm pretty happy with this.
Owen better like this or
else I'm turning him crispy.
Let's see what he thinks.
- All right, Gideon.
Let's see what we got.
- I tried my best and
hopefully you like it.
Ta-da.
- This is nuts.
First looks it's like crazy.
Like in a great way, very cool.
The like chip layer we got going on here
reminds me of chicharon.
So I think what we got
here is gonna be crispy.
Let's just give it a little sound check.
All right, I think we're just
gonna go on with our hands.
This looks very sturdy.
Look at that. I've never been able
to hold a tiramisu in my hands like this.
All right, we're just
gonna go for a big bite.
- Big bite.
(upbeat music)
Now I want one. What?
- Wow.
- Let me try a bite.
- I think you just bit
my finger a little bit,
but that's cool.
(staff laughs)
That one's crispy.
You nailed the mascarpone cream
that just really resembles
a classic tiramisu.
Had the hint of cocoa.
I will say the one thing
it's kind of lacking.
(tense suspenseful music)
coffee flavor.
- That's what I was thinking earlier.
I thought it was enough.
- I didn't get any sort of hint of coffee,
which some people argue
they don't like tiramisu
because of that.
I personally do.
Yeah, I think creatively
it's like a 10 out of 10.
Also like I'm eating with my
hands it was a lot of fun.
If you guys just rewind
and listen to that bite.
- You think I still hold the
title of the Crispy King?
- I think it would be a dishonor
if I didn't call you the
Crispy King after that.
So you are for sure still the Crispy King.
- Yeah, that's right.
(Owen laughs)
I'm just glad you liked it, man.
- Dude, that was so sweet.
Thank you.
- All right, guys. Thank you for watching.
If you have any foods that
you want me to crisp-ify
leave it in the comments below
and we'll see you next time.
- Bye.
(upbeat music)